lorenzo baldé nivaquine votre fils que
l'étude les succubes pardonnez-moi
d'issoudun est infestée de sans culottes
et celle et il vaut mieux que je me
joins à votre petite troupe mon
personnage c'est le marquis et lorenzo
baldelli markit portofino qui vient se
coller à godefroy et jacquouille qu'il a
rencontré en prison et il se dit qu'avec
avec eux je pense qu'il est tiré
d'affaires ne les lâche pas quand je
pense à la grande époque mon beau-père
avait l'immense honneur de porter la
chandelle de louis cainne selon le roi
chier sur sa chaise percée au milieu de
ses courtisans
j'ai envie de le voir ce film j'ai envie
de le voir